[Music]
hello there fortnight chapter 2 season 8
has given us a supernatural storyline to
follow in-game as well as some other
shenanigans in comic books over the
course of 82 days or seven million
seconds if you prefer season eight has
led up to the end of existence so like
usual i'm here to recap the last few
months my creator code is adamaru if you
fancy slapping that in before the new
chapter begins but right now let's break
down season eight
during the final week of season seven an
alien race with a mother ship spanning
the entire fortnight island were finally
defeated after months of ongoing war
with io long story short we bodied the
mother ship and blew it to pieces we
should note though that dr sloan the i o
agent who recruited us planned for us to
die on that wreckage but it's all good
we survived and season 8 began
it turns out the last reality's mother
ship contained hundreds and thousands of
cubes dark energy like the one we saw in
chapter one back in 2018. half a dozen
of these things landed on the island
sitting dormant along with alien
wreckage and the crashed mothership in
the distance but there was also two
other cubes that day a golden yellow one
and a blue one the blue cube was
reactivated and rebooted during the sky
fire event and since falling to the
ground below hasn't moved in iota
nothing at all 12 weeks of nothingness
but he does give out shield energy if
you grind up against him the yellow cube
on the other hand is powerful in ways we
do not understand upon landing outside
holy hedges the cube began to roll
around and visit the purple cubes this
caused them to have children baby cubes
sprang to life and followed their
parents as they rolled around seemingly
aimlessly each family of cubes left this
strange corruption behind them yeah
minion since day one of this chapter
there have been three hidden bunkers on
the island which last season were
revealed to lead to an underground base
controlled by the imagined order
suddenly a fourth bunker appeared just
south of pleasant park this was either
uncovered by the alien crash debris or
this is part of io's plan fast forward
to the end of the season and this
becomes much more clear but three months
ago this was all speculation our last
clue in week one saw the island's gnomes
begin to leave one by one they packed up
their things hopped on a bus or a boat
and evacuated it was devastating
[Music]
the next major update to the story saw
dr sloane in motion with a new plan she
and her elite unit were spotted on the
far east of the island assessing alien
tech seemingly destroyed in the sky fire
event a flatbed truck was called over
and all that chimera grade engineering
was placed on top of it and sloane's
team began travelling south and speaking
of chimera one of those beings survived
and is the last of his race he set up in
a new home all alone near steamy stacks
he doesn't get out much so please go
visit him one of the battle pass
characters began giving us the ability
to fund the war efforts against the last
reality each week we could unvault
something and this magical monkey would
deliver it without fuss including a
freaking salvaged brute in the last
weeks of the season
the following update saw the golden cube
reach steamy stacks a place which had
been using kevin the cube as a power
source for years the golden cube not
only brought kevin back to us but it
also ripped straight through steamy
stacks leaving devastation behind
a great touch saw kev out written on the
ground and unlike the other cubes kevin
did not spawn offspring and his
movements were much more erratic he sat
looking out over a hill for days at one
point just thinking about life this cube
is not like the others and another one
that's not like the others is the blue
one and yes it still hasn't moved this
update also reverted some strange
anomalies found in the world which saw
chapter 1 assets used on the chapter 2
map an og chest was discovered at a
disused i o base and the original road
textures from chapter 1 appeared in the
swamps both were quickly reverted so
this doesn't mean anything right
[Music]
week 5's update saw the final purple
cubes awoken and it became apparent they
were all heading to the center of the
island the aftermath was becoming the
convergence the golden cube was the
first to arrive and began powering up
ominously meanwhile sloane and her
troops continue to travel south narrowly
avoiding being crushed by one of those
wandering cubes by the end of this week
all the cubes except the blue one had
completed their journey and joined the
golden block at the convergence
something big was coming
the sixth week of the season gave us the
official reveal of the cube queen the
secret character of the season she was
hiding in the gold cube all along the
last reality has a leader and this is
her after summoning all the purple cubes
to her side she manifested this a cube
town who'd have thought this would
become a pyramid for the remainder of
the season queenie sat in her ball
plotting our demise and let's remember
her only words to us directly are these
leave nothing behind
doesn't she sound nice
this week also saw the halloween update
in fortnite we get every year and
everything became more spoopy and the
caretakers came out in force controlled
once again by the cube queen
week 7 update and something finally
happened we'd been hoping for for years
the redacted bunker near katy corner
opened today sloan and her i o squad
arrived here to give us a tour and it's
one of the most underwhelming rooms i've
ever seen it's just another io
stronghold but wait hold your horses
there is law here after seven weeks on
the road collecting chimera tech and
bringing it here we see io are analyzing
the technology to find strengths and
weaknesses and ultimately a way to fight
the cube queen sloan must be low on
options to be using this facility but at
least she now has a quick way to get
around the island using the imagined
orders underground facility i wonder
where she may be going
[Music]
when week 8 arrived a new update dropped
too yet this one was not on the island
it was in a parallel story told in a dc
comic book the foundation who cocooned
himself in the spire all those seasons
ago and was eventually ejected from it
by the mothership of the last reality
last season somehow fell through reality
and landed in gotham city he then teamed
up with batman to close a rift in
metropolis with the help of the justice
league long story short only two people
made it into the rift and onto the
island the batman who laughs and the
foundation the foundation quickly won
the fight and has officially escaped the
loop that means he's on the island
somewhere the batman who laughs though
is now stuck inside the loop just like
the rest of us yet he has all his
memories intact thanks to some healthy
plot armor he wears a spiky mask thing
that keeps his memories intact i don't
write the story i just report it if that
made no sense at all please check out a
video i'll link at the end of the video
which goes into way more detail than
that the cube town continued to upgrade
over week 9 and by week 10 it looked
like this
the queen high in the sky surrounded by
a sphere of power on top of a
post-modern pyramid if i had to guess
i'd say this was some sort of beacon
perfectly placed above the zero point
maybe like a lightning rod io's
counter-attack took shape this week too
with the fourth bunker we saw all those
months back on day one of the season
finally being used to bring us a new
location to the map a fort of some sort
is being created the final battle for
reality is coming who is your money on
the cube queen or the imagined order or
could the seven have more to say about
this than we know
as i'm saying this now week 12 has just
begun and the last few days of the
season and the chapter are here the
newly formed base south of pleasant park
is taking shape but let's be honest it's
not looking very professional more like
the fortilla weapons and armaments are
in place and ready to go and there are
some questionable references to previous
seasons in the chapter like tientina's
workbench and brutus's punchback from
season 2. maybe this event will
encompass the entire chapter i do hope
to see midas again the corruption
spreading around the ground has turned
our once vibrant home into an orange
decomposing island the end is in sight
the season and chapter finale is here on
december the 4th so thank the bus driver
one last time and drop at your favorite
spot this island and this chapter will
be over soon so cherish the memories
hopefully we'll see the genomes in
chapter three i'm adam you're awesome
i'll see you at the event
[Music]
you